green
creamy
should we be concerned it's unnecessary
they just make wishes on it in one hand
they're trying to throw it away it keeps
reappearing and they're drunk
oh it's not okay different character
different character this is surprising
to me i love it
[Music]
so where's the other one
i told you the british have probably
looted this place twice over hmm
the british are coming
oh yeah one will have to do a light
skaters
10 rings logo on the ground
what's going on
[Music]
in our home dimension
the newer dimensions
were known as clandestine
as to what we are we've been called
fantastic
unseen the list goes on but what we're
most like
wait she's saying
i'm sorry did you just say jen whoa okay
whoa this show is doing
crazy stuff i did not foresee any of
this
me neither i i don't know what where it
is going but i love it
i love this this is really dope like
what does this gin thing mean for kamal
i don't know
let's talk about it welcome back to new
rockstars miss marvel episode 3 veered
into a direction i think few of us
expected it to with the mentions of gins
clandestines the 10 rings
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's official after show for ms
marvel on disney plus i'm eric voss my
easter egg breakdown for this episode is
gonna come out tomorrow after my
breakdown for the obi-wan kenobi finale
i hope you forgive me i gotta get to
that one first uh but with me right now
reacting to episode three of ms marvel
is mt
i did not think that the ten rings would
connect to the bengal at all but you and
many others who theorized that were
absolutely right i have to give you uh
all the credit for that i think that is
uh i did not see this coming but i like
i'm actually genuinely happy to uh to
not know what is coming next i think
right they're kind of moving in two
different directions right bringing in
some uh deep cut marvel names and uh
things from mythology that i honestly
think is
really cool so cool so mega cool i have
no i like i really love that they're
leading into this clandestines room
because like no one really knows what
the clandestines really are it's a very
obscure
group in the marvel comics i i cannot
tell you one clandestine fan no offense
marvel but like i i really love that
they're doing this because not not a lot
of people know about the clandestine so
anything could happen like we're gonna
be surprised no matter what so like
that's what's really dope about this i
love it right i think they intentionally
chose the clandestines because fans
don't have that strong attachment to
them so that they can have like a
different name for them
but i also feel like marvel can like
doesn't even have to pull a name from
the comics at all they can just say like
we're just called gin and that's it um
but it actually is a
is connect it's not a completely random
choice either because the clandestines
actually do have an important tie to the
mythology uh we'll we'll talk about that
a little bit imagine they're all um
we're the gin humans not in humans the
gin humans
oh no
someone definitely lose me
if they do that
oh my god
okay so in this episode of miss marvel
we flashed back to the pre-partition
india in 1942 showing najma and her
other companions digging through some
rubble to find the severed blue hand
wearing the bangle and joining them is
aisha kamala's great grandmother
thankfully uh uh najma is not her great
grandmother that would have scared the
hell out of us music
uh makes a lot more sense now seeing it
this way uh but they discussed how this
man in a temple told them that there
would be two of these bangles and these
bangles would help them get home aisha
puts on the bangle uh her eyes glow
purple and then we see on the floor of
this site is the logo of the ten rings
yeah and we all lose it i lost it so
exciting
so mysterious but actually starts to
answer quite a few questions about
what's happening in phase four uh but
i'll get to that again in a moment uh in
the present though najman cameron tell
this story to kamala right and uh they
claim that uh or at least najma claims
that they got separated from aisha
but we didn't see that in the flashback
we just have to take our word for
sketching we meet the others
a little sketchy we meet the others in
our group including faria adam and
celine and then najma explains that they
come from another dimension called the
nor
nor being the word for light
and uh by the way that's not really a
thing in marvel comics i don't think
it's just a new thing that the show is
introducing and uh that they have gone
by many names over the years i love it
whenever marvel does this kang the
conqueror did this i haven't had many
names
uh
she mentions ash nabi majnun and the
unseen various other names the list goes
on but best known as jin d
dj
we heard that in episode one we started
to talk about it and man
like who would have thought the one time
i don't really uh double down on demons
being the answer is the time it actually
is
i freaking love this so much man like i
really hope that like that this isn't
like a red airing it's like all right no
you're actually a gin you're part demon
and uh
i just think it's a really interesting
take on this um the origin story like i
would have never ever guessed that they
would go this route kamala debriefs
bruno who says that he read a paper from
a familiar name dr eric selvig hey it's
still in scholarships characters
that's right or we hope it we hope he's
got underwear on because sometimes
a bit too much
you never know with that guy um uh so
bruno is gonna do some research about
interdimensional travel um the dodc
agent dever tries to search the mosque
but newly elected board member nakia
tells her to f right off until she gets
bored let's go love this that's my
president yeah that's my president
um we just spent much of this episode at
the wedding festivities of kamala's
brother amir and his uh fiancee now
white taisha and it it's just so great i
i loved all this i loved this was i
usually don't like dancing sequences but
i was like this is really nice this is
wholesome like i like this this this
works and like a pakistani wedding it's
so beautiful yeah i was invited to one
of them uh some of our close friends
they got married a few years ago i
couldn't make the trip and now i wish
that i had because uh it just looks like
a blast although you know when bruno
jumps in there
i can tell everybody in the audience was
like the car cassidy of this [ __ ] i
can't even believe it
i mean look the whole family loves bruno
you seem very welcome by them it was
fine i'm just saying like for all of us
watching i just know that if i were the
bruno in that scenario i think they
would have stopped the music and said
hey
we love you just
this is our thing
whatever we're having a blast it's fine
um
one of my favorite moments this episode
and he was youssef talking to bruno at
the circle q explaining gin folklore yes
i think these two are my favorite
relationship with the series
so much her dad is the best the absolute
best he's just chilling he was like yo
don't tell my wife i'm getting missed
because it's not good for me um but also
here's the
you i'm gonna translate these uh
freaking things that you're doing this
casually and just be like all right bye
and i have to shout out bishop ali for
her writing on this series because this
is not an easy thing to do introduce
exposition in all these different ways
each episode reveals to us more and more
exactly what we need to know for each
episode i feel like we are learning so
much about the world each episode but
never feels like it's too much never
just feels like it's just run on
sentences of people talking it's always
like a uh this new interesting character
combination uh and you know as we saw in
shows like hawkeye falcon and the winter
soldier nothing against those shows but
it is really hard to structure
exposition in a way
that both keeps the mystery alive but
doesn't feel like they're annoyingly
withholding anything from you like every
time i have a question on this show the
next scene answers it in a fun way and
that's really really impressive like uh
i think i think ms marvel is on par with
loki when it comes to world building and
expectation management
maybe it's too soon for me to pay that
praise but i think this show is doing a
great job like this could have been a
complete whiplash and we'd all be
confused but no they like they explain
everything you need to know
yeah and i and i
give them a lot of credit for that oh no
like i definitely agree like especially
with the whole uh questions being
answered thing like they answer
questions but also while also still
keeping this general mystery that keeps
you interested in learning more about
like this this universe and like this
part of um you know the marvel universe
and kamala's family and come on his life
and like kamala's whole mysterious
lineage um so like yeah it's it's it's
they have a perfect balance of like all
right we're gonna give you some mystery
but we're gonna give you some answers
but not too many answers because right
this is a journey here um so yeah i love
this this is a really great job by the
writers uh and also we got to talk about
how like how fast this episode moves
like it introduces information then we
have some comic relief like the pacing
of this show is all really great it's
just like a fun i thought it was just
gonna be a fun vibe but like i i'm so
curious to learn more and to learn more
and to learn more about these people and
every character on the show is a fully
fleshed out human being even amir amir
is worried about his economic anxieties
and his new marriage we even get this
nice little moment where amir's like i
can't flee this place i need to get the
it was like money out of his arms
oh my god like every character no one
just feels like they're just uh
like playing a plot role in fact i would
say only so far the maybe some of the
members of the gin uh the clandestines i
don't know but it's they're new we don't
know everything about them yet but we
know enough about them right
so um bruno says they they can't help
the clandestines get back home without
risking destructive energy surges to
this dimension to kamala some second
thoughts on helping them but cameron
texts her back you know just worry about
your family's wedding today we'll talk
about it we'll figure it out um
we could yeah as you mentioned some
amazing dance sequences at the wedding
it is delightful i mean as a uh a
musical theater nerd growing up i want
everyone to burst into song and dance in
every single one of these shows i don't
care what genre it is the boys last week
was in
incredible yes to me
i love it i understand it's not for
everyone when people bursted a song and
dance uh and at least it's obviously
grounded they're at a wedding and it
makes sense for them to be doing these
choreographed dances uh i just think
it's so great i love that the parrots
are getting in there i love that little
kid that nephew with wearing the hulk
outfit
just inexplicably like yeah
i'm a living easter egg
so uh cameron arrives you know bruno's
pissed he's like i can't even have this
dance with him bruno the look on his
face
says can i dance
bruno man he really it was like milhouse
lower those eyebrows like he was ready
but he stole my milhouse
of the series and the other one but
najma is on her way kamali clears the
floor with a fire alarm the clandestines
show up and they fight her in bruno and
they fight cameron they fight everybody
the fight is
fine
it's fine like i think ultimately right
now we just don't know what exactly the
gin's power sets are they're supposed to
be like other dimensional uh beings with
some kind of powers she said that the
nor exists in them in a smaller amount
but we didn't really see that it's
they're just kind of pulling weapons off
their belt and right you know pulling
weapons off of their whatever that was
their necklace and they'd kind of
produce these melee weapons um but if
these are like demons they are not very
scary it kind of felt like
well we can't have them beat the crap
out of kids
right
kamala to her credit
holds her own it's just this whole fight
was a little bit like okay i understand
i understand it's okay yeah they
definitely felt like more super soldiers
than anything um it just felt like this
magical
super soldiers and like they were
punching crack punching cracks in the
floor and like yeah it's just like i
don't really see the the demon nature so
like i'm sort of just maybe thinking
that like maybe over the years they were
just called demons by humans because of
they just didn't understand
what they were what these super soldiers
were but like yeah i'm wondering to see
how that whole demon aspect and how the
whole gin aspect is going to pay off in
the end here yeah um but yeah
yeah during the fight najma grabs a
bengal and then a portal open showing
that train that we had heard last
episode now we just fully see it
hogwarts express coming in here but it
says karachi on it
look out uh and then the dodc arrives
knocks him out with some sonic hulk guns
arresting them kamala escapes nakia
realizes uh kamal has powers kamala
refuses to tell her family the truth but
her grandmother sana calls she missed
the wedding and she tells kamala that
she also saw the vision of the train and
she needs to get her ass to pakistan
asap
so we learned a lot of new words this
episode jizz clandestines we saw the ten
rings we saw blue severed arm
let's make sense of this yes
[Music]
that's what inside marvel is for some
quick announcements new rock is going to
be live in austin texas on july 1st
through the 3rd for rtx it's rooster t's
podcast festival our live show is going
to be saturday july 2nd it's just going
to be a blast click the link in the
description use the promo code new
rockstars all one word for a discounted
ticket price we really hope to see you
there it's gonna be a lot of fun yeah we
love rooster teeth yes our friends at
rooster teeth are amazing we also want
to shout out our merch partners who
still have a limited number of ms marvel
inspired latest obsession shirts cosmic
daydream available at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's the best way
to support us here at new rockstars and
when you get one of these you'll unlock
the added option to write them a custom
shout out that will appear at the bottom
of these after shows for example jose
says would kamala's powers be amplified
if she fights next to captain marvel i
don't know if they'd be amplified but i
think they're going to be like better
defined right especially if the bangle
uh is
you know itself a form of creed
technology if you know carol danvers
powers were derived from cree tech maybe
i don't know if they'd be amplified
though i don't know if they'd be
amplified just because of proximity but
like
yeah like at the most like she'd just
get the help of captain marvel and so
like the marvel power to be amplified in
general right but like yeah i don't
think that you would be stronger um
kashan says riri williams is iron lad
she will be kang's daughter or his
variant
uh that's a very interesting theory yeah
greery williams i i
i think she's iron heart i think he's
saying like iron heart could just be the
ensued version of iron lad
all right
plausible i just think iron heart has
her own backstory in her own uh
character i don't think she needs to be
related to kang in that way but i like
your i like where your head is at kashan
yeah i think it's very good for sure um
and then thomas says i would sell
bootleg eric voss merch at avenger con
don't tell me that thomas i'm gonna send
my lawyers after you
i'm just kidding i don't have lawyers i
don't have lawyers i should get lawyers
right i should get lawyers we should all
get one um all right
mt what's what are we talking about for
this episode all right bro i gotta ask
you here who are the gin aka the
clandestines and how do the bengals
connect to the ten rings so last week we
predicted that if najma cameron and
kamala weren't inhumans and they would
be some other proper noun specific to
this series just some other group and
that's exactly what they did in fact i
should have stuck to my guns leading
into the series that the answer would be
granted in kamala's spiritual beliefs
because that's exactly what is happening
now hey still points i'll still give you
points for that i'm giving you more
points i really did not think that the
ten rings would come into this uh but
i'm so happy to be wrong here because
this is very exciting to see all this
connect and i think it actually makes a
lot of sense um really we should point
out this series is at least at this
point it seems like dramatically
changing kamala's origin from the comics
uh and as i predict in our preseason
episode they're grounded it more in the
era that the mcu seems to be in at the
moment and based on moon knight and thor
love and thunder wakanda forever
eternals that theme is faith how the
spiritual beliefs of characters in the
mcu inform their power sets now sure on
in one corner of the mcu we're
definitely exploring the multiverse with
kang and incursions and all that great
stuff but on this whole other level of
the mcu we're exploring religion and i
for one am fascinated i'm here for it
this is an incredibly bold vector for
marvel studios to explore and
thematically it's far more uncharted
because yeah we've seen the multiverse
uh trope done pretty well in lots of
other ips like from everything dan
harmon has touched to everything
everywhere all at once and we haven't
though spent enough time i think in
what i call the neil gaiman territory
right
how superheroes intersect with religion
and spiritual beliefs of characters how
they're basically gods uh so now i can't
wait for the mcu to explore this i think
it's
not at all what i expected phase four
would explore i thought they would touch
on it but now they're like making it
their core theme of this of this era and
oh yeah for sure super exciting you see
it with uh miss marvel we see it with
thor 11 thunder obviously moon knight
like this we're definitely going to the
more spiritual side of things and like i
need to see more like i love how the mcu
is interpreting things in our reality in
their own way and explaining it with a
marvel flair and like man what they're
doing with the gods is so freaking cool
and i can't wait to learn more about the
science of the gods it's really dope
yeah now uh let's define some terms here
gin right this was mentioned back in
episode one it refers to the spiritual
beings from islamic folklore seen as
demons or boogeymen but they've been
anglicized as genies right so i think at
some point in my upbringing they're like
oh so jin or what we call genies and
it's like no it's not what we call
genies it's like we distorted and
bastardized the concept of what gin
that's supposed to be
into a blue robin williams uh dancing
around tap dancing like that's not what
jen are in fact like uh as kamala
explains this episode and as her father
explains to bruno there's a a deeper
darker lore to them uh they are more
frightening beings you know um
and uh oh fun fact that we should
mention qui-gon jinn's name actually
came from the term gin
right uh so that's how ironic is it that
the disneyland
today yes
so
but we have to define clandestine okay
so uh this is an actual group in marvel
comics from the 90s created by alan
davis founded uh by this guy named adam
of ravencroft from 1168 in england his
kid was impaled on a scythe and renamed
adam of destin because they're like wow
this guy can survive anything he's
destined for great things
so this young hero joins a crusade you
know at this time that's when a lot of
these european powers were headed to the
middle east to reclaim the holy land
that's where he went and during all
these uh adventures he was dreaming of
this mystery woman in his in his visions
and his dreams don't we all
yeah
he gets kidnapped by a warlord uh and
goes through all the stuff with him but
is later saved by a female spirit that
is contained in a gem and that spirit is
later revealed to be named uh ellalith i
think
i was struggling with this name last
night too i was like
i don't know
uh
she's a gin she is definitively a gin
and she becomes his lover they have all
these immortal descendants and they
become known as clan destine the clan of
dustin right
and
in the comics there's like a whole bunch
of them they have different powers
they're similar to the mutants they
cross paths with the x-men uh they were
brought back in 2008
nothing against clandestine but um they
weren't really hits yeah everyone right
now who talks about marvel stuff was
doing some research on clayton's day
last night because i don't think i don't
know anyone who had read clintus
bro like i know a lot of marvel i've
only heard that name once in passing i
do not know what the claptons were last
night but i know them now
they are a deep cut and i think that's
by design i don't think they were chosen
because you know people are gonna be
like oh yes finally clint that's not
no no i think kevin feige is like give
me the name of the most obscure group
uh
that we can change but also i think this
history with these people who do not age
people connected to the gin mythology
they're obviously changing it but i
think it's it's specific for i think
they want to throw that in as a nod to
the fact that
adam uh had that kind of history with
the jinn also one of the people in this
group group is named adam he's spelled
differently but
is he adam of of uh of destiny
we don't know
it seems like najma and aisha were
leading this group we also don't know
how long they've been around we don't
really know how they got in this
dimension you know what how long they've
been vanished here and you know what's
what's also super interesting is like we
have the names aisha and adam um in this
you know
team that is all about energy which is
what you know the sovereign are all
about in on their planet so i'm just
like is this intentional like is there
like a hidden meaning behind these names
like i know that um the name aisha if
i'm not mistaken um means like she was
long-lived or something like that i
googled this once last night i totally
forgot um i think it means like more
like a long-lived person so like i'm
wondering if like there's like a
specific reason why like they're they're
linking these like this name aisha to
long-lived people like i think the the
sovereign are the the peak of their
evolution so like i'm assuming they live
long um so like i'm wondering what the
connection here with these names are and
why they chose you know adam and aisha
and that combination um but that's just
me redwood you bring you bring up an
interesting parallel there for sure
empty absolutely at the moment it seems
like marvel studios is taking this
lesser-known family of super powered
beans from the comics redefining them as
jin from islamic folklore and then
coming from a dimension called the nor
dimension nor means light this is the
purple color dimension that kamala
briefly transported to in episode one
pretty sure now that the other beings
she saw there were likely other gin or
people from that home dimension
at least like they're known as jin in
this dimension uh but they may just have
a completely different name as as uh as
najma uh hints at in this episode um
however while we're grounded everything
in islamic folklore
space is still a big part of this
because these bangles are not something
from the gin's dimension they found it
in this dimension as a way to possibly
get home and they came to the mcu by way
of the ten rings hey yes our friends the
ten rings from
the legend of the tin rings an ancient
society of warriors led by win woo after
he found uh these ten rings these ten
rings that he wears as bracelets
in the movie shangqi they do not say or
show where he found them at some point
jai ling says that he found them in a
crater but we never actually saw that or
what that crater looked like we may be
seeing that crater here now shanxi ended
with wong discovering a pulsing beacon
hidden in those ten rings summoning
something uh in the comics the ten rings
are alien tech it's called mccluentek
each ring in the comics is said to
contain the spiritual essence of an
ancient mcluhan warrior and uh each ring
has a different power set we didn't see
that in the movie it kind of seemed like
they all just kind of had this uh
concussive power to them uh that just
make you punch stronger and you can kind
of float with them um in the comics it
was the mandarin who found them when was
loosely based on the mandarin uh and he
found them in like the crashed wreckage
uh of uh of the mcluhan extraterrestrial
whom we called uh the dragon or at least
we didn't i didn't you know ever i
wasn't reading the comments in the 70s i
wasn't alive yet but it was called the
the dragon named fang fume which also
was left out of uh of the shanghai movie
just because obviously that name has
some uh that
great good cut good cut but what is
interesting now is that the jin are
discovering only one of the two bangles
that some man in a temple told them to
find
empty i think that man in the temple was
wen wu we know when wu was alive at this
point wynwoo has always been long he's
been alive for like a thousand years uh
i think this rubble in india was the
crater was the site that uh the same
place where he found the ten rings i
think we are looking at a cree crash
site and we know that the ten rings were
everywhere across the asian continent in
in china modern day china they were as
uh
definitely as far
west yeah as far west as like
afghanistan like it was meant to be like
a empire spanning the globe the way
genghis khan's empire did i think this
bengal right now is the same kind of
alien tech that the ten rings are um but
i think one of those bengals was stolen
was taken from the site not just that
the british had already gone through
this site meaning the other bengal where
is the other bengal i think it's
somewhere in the uk
that's right that's right get killmonger
on this
we need to be robbing more museums it
could be among the the possessions of
dane whitman's uncle
uh because he's got the ebony blade
there are there other things that he has
there could it be with blade and mi-13
that's the supernatural division where
he teams up with black knight maybe moon
knight could be involved with this we
are exploring more of the supernatural
side of the mcu now again we have to
talk about this severed arm was blue and
the mcu blue-skinned aliens are usually
cree they aren't the only blue-skinned
aliens out there in the mcu but i think
that could mean that kritek is is
definitely involved in the bengal maybe
the term inhuman could come up on the
series i would say don't hold your
breath because they're using a whole
other glossary of terms it looks like
but yes i think this bengal and the tin
rings are both cree tech cree technology
invented by imperialist crete i think
this was uh the ship there was a ship in
ancient times that crashed on earth
containing cree tech these are ancient
cree
over a thousand years ago who came to
earth maybe in that time created in
humans we don't know yet but i think on
this ship were things like the tin rings
and things like the bengals one of the
bengals ended up in the hands of some
british colonizers the other one stayed
here in the rubble found by the gin so
this isn't all coming from one place
right we have cretech from space and
then we have the gin coming from another
dimension
i think that ten rings beacon is
summoning the cree
to reclaim this important tech of theirs
and i think that is setting up the
marvels that's why carol danvers was in
that scene and she's like it's more it's
beyond any tech i've seen now she's
obviously pretty familiar with cretex
she spent quite a bit of time on holla
but i think this predates her i think
this is from ancient gree times and
she's just not studied up on her hala
history
i think this proves to us that in the
marvels carol danvers monica rambo and
kamala khanna are going to have to
defend earth from a cree invasion i
think secret invasion is going to show
us a shadow ward i think that's going to
spill out into an open hostile hot war
between the kree and the scrolls on
earth and i think those three women are
going to have to team up to defend us
from their cree invaders from these
imperialists um so meanwhile i think the
gin have been trapped in the earth
dimension and they hope that the creed
bengals is just a technology they don't
fully understand and will be powerful
enough to open a portal back to their
home dimension regardless of the
consequences but what was that in order
to mention how do they get here well
remember in chiang chi non referred to
alternate realms and civilizations
beyond our own the gin could have been
outcasts from one of those they aren't
all gin who live in that dimension
they're other dimensional beings but
here they're kind of banished here in
the mcu on this earth dimension
to kind of walk the earth as these kind
of ghostly figures um now
i think we're going to learn that this
nor dimension could be one of the
afterlifes of the mcu part of the same
network that we know the ancestral plane
is connected with the duat tower had
explained that there are various
afterlifes in the mcu and they go by
different names i i think the nord
dimension is a different one uh but is
also considered an afterlife
and these gin
like ghosts in various other mythologies
are banished to walk this mortal plane
unwelcomed by that afterlife damn so
that's i think the nord dimension is
just like another version of the
ancestral plane another version of the
duat i think people who go they go there
when they die but these gin were
outcasts from that for whatever reason
right they had some drama or maybe their
souls were kind of cursed in some way
obviously that's a lot empty but since
you're the one who figured out that the
tin rings was connected to this i defer
to your expertise what are your thoughts
man i mean i really love this idea of
like the the cree getting this beacon
like and it's like oh my god like the
humans are ready for for for whatever we
need them for we're like or our ten
rings or all of our objects are over
here let's go get them i really like
that idea like i honestly think that you
know 10 rings and these bangles could be
a lot older than even the cree
civilization i think that these could
like have come like millions of years
ago in that comet of vibranium that
crashed on earth um like a long time ago
and like because like we were you
mentioned killmonger earlier and i was
thinking of that museum scene of like
remember when he puts on that um that
mask and it's like a demon and like it's
like all right this is part of like
culture like
the demons existed in this culture a
long time ago and it was like i think
that that's important i think
that these like demon creatures probably
came with this asteroid maybe and um you
know like in all of like of the the 10
rings and the bangles and like the
vibranium in general all of these items
like because we know from um
from the end of shanghai that they were
analyzing the ten rings and they were
like all right there's this isn't really
a material that we've seen before so
like they've only and they say that it
wasn't vibranium so i'm just like all
right vibranium is like a very rare
metal that came from outer space so like
what if other rare metals like you know
the the metals found in the ten rings
and like this this new bangle what if
they are all part of this package of
foreign metals from a different planet
and like all right here you go um so
yeah i think that you know these ten
rings have like a more much more
um
older history and possibly i think that
maybe even of the gin and these bangles
could have come from the realm of talo
because we know from chongqi a talo is a
separate universe um like a neighboring
universe from the 616. so like i'm
thinking that these gin people possibly
could have just been exiled from from
the realm of talo because they were just
being jerked and they want to get back
um and because because we know that i'm
sean chi's mom she's from another
universe so she's like she is
not native here and like his dad is from
this universe so a very similar
situation um with chongqi and i think
that they might be setting up a team for
like maybe kamala and chungchi and like
maybe other people um to make a little
clandestine team for the mcu that'd be
really fun um but yeah i think that
these um these rings the the ten rings
and all this stuff it's it's a much
older than prob probably even the planet
um but
that's just me that's that's that's
pretty old pretty old i mean i think
it's ultimately
you're right i think it is uh and the
cree as a as a species predates humanity
by
all those years right like
a long time we saw kind of the origin of
the humans of earth and eternals we saw
the sumerian civilization that was uh
5000 bc roughly um
and that's uh the earliest uh signs of
civilization we really know of there's
obviously other other
civilizations around the planet but it's
not like we really had any uh
intelligence civilization form before 10
000. uh in the mcu uh 10000 bc was
really when the five tribes of wakanda
came together and i've always loved the
understanding of the mcu that that
vibranium meteorite striking wakanda is
is the what-if scenario that made the
mcu different from our reality uh that
is the one thing that changed that's the
one thing that's different and then
everything else kind of stemmed from
that it's that that was yeah that was
the next event uh and then maybe see i
don't know if uh i think that's an
interesting theory that um these bengals
or these other things could have been on
that meteorite as well but i i don't
know if they were on the meteorite but i
do think that they were connected right
i think the kris saw that meteorite
strike uh terra and was like oh so they
got some early tech there's a there's a
group there who's now starting to build
that and weaponize that they're ready
for a higher form of war and sent this
this cree warship there um so the crease
started to experiment maybe create
inhumans things like that uh things went
wrong obviously uh when wu ended up with
the tin rings someone else ended up with
these bangles etc and uh i i think
ultimately you're right i think they do
come from another dimension i think it's
one of the ones that was hinted at
beyond tallow personally um but i'm
wondering like was there someone they
pissed off like and the way that you
know love and thunder is gonna introduce
us to the pantheon of deities uh maybe
one of these characters you know they'll
say like what maybe we'll meet some
other grouch who's sitting in one of
those thrones
who has a reputation for casting people
out of his or her afterlife
uh
and that you and i will be able to
connect that back to these gin here in
ms marvel um we'll find out for sure but
i mean this is leading me to some pretty
crazy directions i don't really want to
get there yet but we'll get there later
this episode this episode was so
exciting i love it first we want to
thank some friends who helped us make
this episode it's starting with our
friends at blue chew summer is here and
the temperature isn't the only thing
that is rising yes this episode was
brought to you by blue chew fellas
confidence can take you far in life it
can also help in the bedroom that's
where blue chew comes in blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime date or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready for whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days it's all
done online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line the pharmacy bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform bluetooth can help and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners to try bluetooth free when you
use our pro code marvel at checkout just
pay five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code marvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this show we
also want to thank stance for sponsoring
this episode we love us some stance
socks around the new rockstars office
they're they fit great and have cool
designs made with brands like marvel
pixar mlb nba the simpsons they even
have a new line inspired by fortnite let
everyone know that you're glad no build
mode is here stance is branching out
beyond socks to bring color comfort and
creativity from toe to head with the
launch of a new active apparel line
check out stance's super soft line of
sweatpants shirts hoodies hats and more
now available in a full range of fits
prints and fabrics and fun embrace the
life of superior comfort and creative
expression with everyday active apparel
that truly is stitched different
stance's philosophy is that you should
never have to sacrifice your own
individual style for the sake of comfort
and now you do not have to whether
you're relaxing around the house working
out at the gym or running all over town
stance now delivers its signature
softness and creativity and a full line
of active apparel styles from toe to
head stance has got you covered head on
over to stance.com and get 15 off your
first purchase use promo code marvel at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different all right back
to the episode
mt so we know that ms marvel was setting
up the marvels right and we seem to have
this like cree conflict coming
especially if the ten rings are revealed
to be cree and these bengals are
revealed to be cree but in the meantime
we're also exploring more of the
supernatural side so i want to ask you
is ms marvel setting up blade
hm
i think that
you know
miss marvel could be a a continuation of
like what blade is doing because we saw
at the end of eternals that uh he's
collecting all of these artifacts that i
mean i'm assuming that he's collecting
all these artifacts that seem to be a
little bit too much for humanity to
handle and so like i think that the the
ten rings and possibly these bangles
could fall under this category and so
blade could show up like at the end when
the dodc fails to capture kamala it's
like hey i keep keeping an eye on you
and uh i'm supposed to collect that but
i'm just gonna let you have it because
uh you seem to be pretty good with it um
this is like if you want to join the
midnight suns here's my car sort of a
scenario
but even though that'll be hilarious i
don't think miss marvel is going to be
on the midnight suns that would be so
funny uh but um yeah i i think that you
know it's tangentially related to blade
but like i don't know if they're setting
up blade through the marvels but like i
think that blade might be like
sort of involved just because of the
cosmic nature of this artifact but what
do you think
i mean i it's i didn't expect this at
all going to this series but like right
now like
we could the dodc we don't really know
exactly what their main focus is they
seem to just be worried about
quote-unquote enhanced individuals but
as we you know pivot from the show to
she-hulk i think we're gonna be seeing
more examples of supernatural beings
werewolves zombies vampires etc and the
more we get shoutouts to those things
the more likely blade could show up uh i
don't know if it'll be the midnight
sun's first i think we're going to see
some investig uh investigatory unit
maybe under the dhdc or in conjunction
with the dodc that's why i brought up
mi13 mi13 is like the british
intelligence service
where black knight teams up with uh with
blade and other people to investigate
and deal with these paranormal threats
uh i i'm just like i wouldn't surprise
me at this point i'm like equally on the
fence of cleary is a skrull and cleary
is a vampire hunter right it seems like
either direction could be valid doesn't
it i would love to see clearly hunting
vampires that'd be so funny
but yeah i think uh i think you're right
every marvel show it's gonna start to
give us more and more of these uh these
things from folklore things from
supernatural paranoia uh paranormal
phenomena uh
and
i think uh jyn are part of that part of
that ecosystem and to that point i have
to ask mt is mephisto back on the table
hear me out hear me
yo i'm here let's go
could mephisto have pit
the demon overlord of the dimension from
which the gin were cast out could
mephisto have banished them to this
dimension i sound crazy that question is
that stupid as i said i don't think no
bro
yeah i don't think this sounds stupid
because we're dealing with demons and
like
mephisto he's the ultimate demon
ultimate
we know that the ms marvel cast is like
into new rock stars they they're big
fans of ours iman valani watches our
videos other people in the cast and crew
watch our videos hey i'm on we love you
and specifically specifically our
pre-season episode where we speculated
that her uh powers are gonna be rooted
in her spiritual beliefs that we know
for sure iman velani said during the
press conference she shared it with the
executive producer on the show they
talked about that and i think that
should have been a clue to us that we
were on the right path on that episode
so maybe the reason is is like iman
secretly knows
that we
we're right about
and the memphis is coming and they just
want us to have a swim oh my god i
wouldn't love it
maybe no i i mean i just don't think so
i don't think so i just like i feel like
he's at least back on the table
it would be such a fun reveal like for
sure it's like oh yeah and you're in
your uh your family line mephisto he
made the bracelets and like now you're
uh part of the devil's no he didn't he
didn't make the bracelets the bracelets
came from pre-tech but i think he's a
look mephisto and jen come from
completely different spiritual belief
systems with this obviously from judeo
christian not even judeo just straight
up christian and catholic folklore from
the from the early
early times whereas jyn is something
from a completely different
completely different faith network i
understand that don't lecture me on that
i know i know guys i know i'm reaching
right now i'm just saying
i'm saying i i did not think that uh
that people's face and their spiritual
beliefs would play such an important
role in this series and i think the more
the mcu does that the more likely people
like mephisto can show up and i think
really mephisto is going to be the
villain of some kind of upcoming
midnight suns that's i don't need
mephisto to show up before that honestly
but if he does
like i feel like if mephisto is for sure
coming to the mcu i feel like there's no
doubt about that he's too big of a name
to knock up to the fcu but yeah i think
that midnight sounds like you said might
be a better a better place to introduce
or make him the big like thanos type of
um
person for that team so yeah for sure so
other questions from this episode
anything else we want to talk about uh
is bruto going to go to caltech dr eric
selvig exploring interdimensional travel
and just put it up online for every
teenager in jersey city to read
i know what the teams like
interdimensional travel papers
but no another thing i just want to
bring up real quick is like we saw that
the ten rings logo was on on the floor
there um like what i honestly think that
agent cleary is working in tandem with
um the ten rings organization and that
this is all possibly gonna tie into
armor wars maybe because um the ten
rings all about technology like they
were obsessed with technology and being
on the cutting edge and like i think
that you know this could be an armor
wars prequel of sorts where it's like
all right here's this cosmic armor um we
want it uh because like this is what the
ten rings does and um we're gonna get it
in one way or the other so like it'd be
really fun if um that's how the ten
rings connect to miss marvel it's like
agent cleary is working with um jai ling
and possibly even the power broker from
madrid i think they'll be really fun
maybe oh maybe uh yeah i don't i think
ultimately every piece of like
weaponized tech that's out there is
going to be playing some kind of role in
armor wars right right um i just think
armor wars is gonna be something on the
other side of the marvel's uh we don't
have a release date yet for armor
warriors
sometime in 2023 i need a release date
and for justin hammer to be confirmed
yeah yes
oh he's already confirmed he's he's at
least
all right well we will leave it there
for this episode of inside marvel i am
loving this show so good loving this
show it's so good i'm having and i like
that i have no idea where it's going
like our friends over at the ringerverse
podcast are calling it the summer of no
expectations and i'm i'm on board with
them like no expectations for these
shows wherever it takes us i'm just
along for the ride and i'm enjoying this
ride so much don't forget to check out
our great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow mt and mastertainment subscribe
to inside marvel wherever your podcast
thanks for watching i'll see you next
week we love you bye we love you bye
you